and we are continuing to cover the
homeless crisis here all across the
valley residents in a Summerlin
neighborhood near where Charleston
becomes Red Rock Canyon say they are
overwhelmed by the growing number of
encampments 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough went to the area to see what
neighbors there are dealing with
located on Highway 159 as you make your
way up to Red Rock Canyon typically a
very scenic view but homeless
encampments have now taken over part of
the trail and community members are
desperate for help I have noticed more
homeless people like walking down
Charleston and we've noticed that and
it's like where are they staying at if
you live or frequent this area of
Summerlin you most likely have seen
these homeless encampments along and
under the bridge if you go down there
you'll see that there's a bunch of tents
a ton of trash there's a school a
quarter of a mile down the road there's
another school a mile up Jeremy boss
contacting 8 news now that local leaders
haven't responded to his concerns I've
sent several emails I've reported on the
uh that click it to fix it Clark County
app nothing gets done you call 311 you
sit on hold for hours Boz reaching out
to Clark County Commissioner Justin
Jones who oversees this area of District
F commissioner Jones team emailed him
back this quote we are all well aware of
the constant issues plaguing this
location and are working diligently to
resolve them we are currently working
with the nearby owners and and other
agencies on looking to come to a
permanent solution boss says while he is
grateful for the response it doesn't
offer a solution which is what he and
his neighbors want I do worry about the
safety I do run fairly often and I just
don't buy the whole oh we're working on
a permanent solution it doesn't say
anything about what the solution is it's
just we're working with our partners and
I spoke to a man who lives in the tents
right over there and when I asked him if
he had ever been forced to move in the
year that he has spent here he said no
reporting in Summerlin Madison kimpro 8
News Now